a lot of our communication is really
about translation translating our ideas
so other people can understand them
being a leader a manager a working
professional part of your job is to
understand the context the knowledge
level the information that you need to
communicate and translate it in a way
that people can understand it and work
on it
my name is Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
today I'm excited to be joined by Greg
LeBlanc who is a lecturer at Stanford
GSB and Berkeley's Hospital of business
his research lies at the intersection of
law Innovation and the use of data in
rapidly changing Industries Greg's
teaching covers many topics including
data strategy digital transformation
human resource strategy and behavioral
Finance Greg also hosts the unsiloed
podcast which recently was added to the
GSB podcast family welcome Greg thanks
Matt great to be here I am super excited
to be chatting with you and I know we're
going to talk about lots of cool topics
including podcasting let's go ahead and
get started you are truly a Renaissance
Man your areas of research and teaching
cover such a wide range of topics I'd
love to focus on a few of these today
that directly relate to communication
let's start by talking about data their
importance in organizational success and
your advice and guidance on how best to
communicate data inside and outside of
an organization well that's that's a
great question so I've been teaching
courses on data for a long time and a
lot of people think of this as a
quantitative topic right where you have
to understand the math and so forth but
but I find that it's equally a
qualitative topic and you have to have
an intuitive understanding of what's
Happening how to ask questions how to
answer questions and so forth and in my
experience if you think you understand
something but you're incapable of
communicating it it probably means that
you don't really understand it and I
think it was Einstein I'm not sure who I
think it was Einstein who said
you can't explain it you know to your
grandmother to a five-year-old then you
know you probably go need to go back and
re-examine what it is that you think you
understand and so and I think that's
true not just for communicating with
others but also you know can you
communicate it with yourself can you put
things in your own words and so I always
encourage students to put what they're
learning into their their own words so
that they can explain it back to
themselves I think all of us who teach
have learned that that having to teach
something really forces you to learn it
in a way that just thinking you know it
doesn't bring you to that same level of
knowledge when it comes to taking
numbers and taking data and
communicating them are there certain
best practices you encourage your
students to think about using analogies
making sure people understand the
baseline or base rates anything in
particular you'd focus on well we have
three different ways of understanding
the world you know we have the the
formulaic way that involves complicated
explanations but we also understand
things through stories and narratives
and we also understand things through
through pictures and images and those
are a little bit deeper they go back a
little further in our evolutionary
history and so I try to encourage
everyone to explain every concept
in each of those three ways and so so
you should be well practiced in you know
Switching gears and switching modes of
explanation in in all three ways so it's
like casting a wide net to bring in as
many people as you can yeah and and I
think that even with the same audience
member if they see all three types of
explanation they're they're going to
learn more than if they're only exposed
to one absolutely it's getting people to
think through different modalities I
think absolutely helps them connect
better and remember more and it also
forces all of us as communicators to
stretch what we're comfortable with
because I think many of us gravitate
towards one of those three and that's
just the way we communicate and by
reminding ourselves that we have to
leverage more can can help us more
accurately communicate the information
we had our colleague Rob Siegel on this
podcast a while back and we discussed
the challenges and benefits of corporate
digital transformation I'm curious to
get your take on how companies and their
employees can avoid some of the common
pitfalls involved in digital
transformation and I'm going to give you
extra credit if you talk about
Communication in your answer well so I'm
gonna I'm trained as a historian and so
historians are always very skeptical
when they're told you know everything's
new we're experiencing unprecedented
change and so forth so we always tend to
look back and say you know what I think
we've seen this this this thing before
so um so I think that we are undergoing
this massive fundamental transformation
but we've been through Transformations
before and I think to be a good manager
you have to be a change manager right it
doesn't take a Stanford MBA sit on top
of a steady state to to just administer
some some inputs and outputs you know to
be someone who can change that function
and radically transform things that's
really the most difficult aspect of
business and so I think that management
today is increasingly change management
now that said of course the specifics of
digital transformation
but it's really about understanding how
to match organizational architecture
with with the technology and if you sort
of bolt on new technologies to existing
organizational architecture existing
incentive structures existing cultures
then you're gonna have a Frankenstein
monster company so it's really about you
know the management and the technology
and how they fit
so it sounds like we we over index on
the technology and we don't think about
the actual specific
interpersonal managerial day-to-day
interaction piece and of course in when
you talk about change management you're
talking about communication how do how
do we align people how do we how do we
articulate clear goals or key
performance indicators how do we get
people in lockstep have you in your in
your classes or or in your experience as
a consultant are there certain traps
that people fall into Beyond not seeing
the change management piece yeah I mean
one of the reasons why I chose the term
on siled for my podcast is because I'm a
big believer in I don't say multitasking
but being multilingual right being able
to understand the discourse of of
different disciplines within the academy
but also understanding the different
discourses of the different kind of
functional areas within a business so I
think many poorly run organizations have
people that are they're overly
specialized and they lack the capacity
to communicate with people in different
functional areas right so oftentimes the
people who are in the tech side of the
business can't talk to the folks in the
business side of the business and vice
versa so I think that in today's world
to be a successful
business person successful management
successful executive you have to be you
know bilingual trilingual quadrilingual
and you have to be able to translate
right so you have to be able to
translate what's going on on the tech
side of the business to the folks who
are you know less tech savvy and you
also need to be able to translate kind
of the business objectives to the folks
who are in the tech trenches and if you
can do that you know and sometimes I
wonkishly say that's like being a human
API right if you can be the human API
within the organization who is the the
connector right the translator then you
will ultimately be you know
indispensable and ultimately you know
super successful I like that notion of
human API being that that interface that
connects and translates I recently
interviewed a a senior leader at the
company that includes Cliff Notes
because I was interested in how do you
relay complex information in a concise
way and he convinced me that it's not
just the transmission of information
it's really about translating that
information
appropriately for the audience that
you're working with and talking to and
that's exactly what you just said as
managers As Leaders part of our job is
to translate information rather than
just broadcast information I think
that's really important
you are clearly a master teacher you
have won numerous teaching Awards can
you share some of your insights and
teaching tactics you use that help that
could help all of us as we Mentor
colleagues and pass along information in
our work
well uh those are those are some nice
kind kind words always think there's
room for improvement in in the world of
of teaching
um but but I think you know when it
comes to to teaching
uh you have to start with respect you
have to respect your students okay you
have to respect where they're coming
from you have to respect what they bring
to the table and you have to understand
that you're going to learn from them
right and if you walk into the teaching
experience with a view to learning then
I think that you'll be successful as a
teacher at Berkeley where I also teach
one of the mottos is students always so
you're gonna be a student for the rest
of your life and if I could go in and
add to that you know I would add a fifth
defining principle which is Teachers
always and being a teacher is being a
student and I remember you know I
started in a Montessori school I did
Montessori through the third grade and I
knew when I was about three years old
when I started Montessori school I want
to be a teacher
because in Montessori school as soon as
you learn something you have to turn to
the people next to you and you have to
teach them
and maybe you start teaching them before
you've even fully ingested what it is
that you're learning and then as you
start teaching it the what you encounter
on the other side of that teaching
interface is is helps you then to go
back and and learn better and so I
really believe in that that Montessori
approach it sort of informed everything
that I've done and so to be to be a
teacher you have to be a good student I
think that's the the one overarching
principle and rule that I would
recommend to every teacher
and while it's it makes sense
intuitively I think a lot of people who
find themselves in positions where they
are teaching people feel like they have
to be the expert like I have to know
this and I know something you don't know
and that sets up a very different
relationship than what you're talking
about which is I have some things that
I've learned that I can pass to you and
you've had some experiences you've
learned that you can pass to me it's
much more collaborative so while it it
sounds intuitive and makes sense I think
a lot of us who find ourselves in
teaching positions don't always adopt
that point of view and the the first
thing you said when I asked the question
you said you really have to understand
where your students your recipients the
people you're mentoring are coming from
so that you can adjust and adapt and
that's a theme that we've heard Lots on
this podcast you have to know who you're
speaking to and how to adjust to that
audience I want to turn now to to your
podcast when you and I first met I was
in awe of the number of episodes you do
and how frequently you do them and the
amount of reading that you do to prepare
yourself you do several episodes a week
and you read several books a week I am a
very slow methodical reader I always
have been it's been a challenge for me
what advice do you have to help people
read more quickly or take in information
more quickly and make it actionable
because you you clearly do that well how
do you do it I want to learn personally
the skill that I've developed is one
that I encourage students to develop and
I think part of what you're learning in
graduate school is you're learning how
to process information more quickly and
effectively and to you know somehow take
this fire hose of of information that's
coming in from all directions and make
sense of it and so if you have
Frameworks right so Frameworks and
theories and models like these are
pre-existing structures which allow you
to as the information comes in in real
time you can sort it like into into
different buckets right so I like to
talk about like a compression algorithm
so you know if you have an image if
you're storing a movie and you go from
frame to frame uh you don't store every
single frame you just store okay what
changed when you go from frame two to
frame one right and that's a tiny tiny
bit of incremental information so when
I'm reading books I'm looking for okay
what what's new here you know what what
lines up with what I already know or
what I've already seen and I just
checked that box and say okay this
person's using this this and this and
this framework to structure this Theory
Etc and then boom when I see the new
stuff that's when my eyes light up so
I'm reading the entire book I'm reading
every word but because it's if it's
familiar it it flows very very smoothly
and then I slow down when I see the
stuff that is that is new
so part of what I'm hearing you say is
that that when you're reading you're
synthesizing and prioritizing and
packaging the information according to
framework structures and theories that
you've already had in place and that's
really insightful for me because I I do
that
retrospectively not concurrently like if
I'm done reading something I'll say oh
that's links here and what I'm hearing
you say is you're doing it in real time
and I can see how that can help me and I
can imagine it would help many of our
our listeners especially when you're
taking on new content or if you're new
to the language that you're learning it
in if you can think about those
heuristics and Frameworks and apply them
in the moment that could really help so
I think you've just made my life easier
I can read more quickly now
well you know we like to end this
podcast by asking the same three
questions of everybody so now it's your
turn are you up for answering the
questions uh yeah I have to give it a
try all right you're gonna do great if
you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title what would it be
I think it would be meet them where they
are right I think it was Ignatius Loyola
that is famous is famous for having said
this first right and I had spent some
time at Jesuit High School and maybe
that's where I picked it up but the idea
is that you people are where they are
and and when you first encounter them
and they're not going to be where you
wish they were and that's why I would
say that you know I don't think of
myself as a great communicator because I
haven't I I have a long way to go
with respect to this principle you know
I communicate best when I encounter
people who enter the interaction with a
lot of curiosity and when I meet people
that maybe are set in their ways if I
don't do so well and so I need to get
better at this but if you don't meet
people where they are then you'll you'll
never get anywhere in in conversation
you'll never get anywhere with
communication you'll never get anywhere
with teaching
I think that's exactly right and again
you're coming back to this theme of
translating and the only way you can
translate is if you know where one
person is to help translate the
information to where they need to be or
you would like to get them and many
people like yourselves who are very good
at communication say the same thing that
that I I need to get better I can get
better I know and so there's this
introspection that comes with good
communication recognizing that there's
more work to be done and that really
motivates what I do in my profession and
the the core of this podcast too
so let me ask you a question number two
who's a communicator you admire and why
this tough one because there are so many
people that that I admire I'd have to go
back to a professor that I had uh the
undergrad and the grad level and and
this this professor was someone who
taught intellectual history and he would
teach every week a different author a
different philosopher a different
literary figure and while he was
teaching that person he would inhabit
them he would become them he would you
know stand up on stage and and you know
as if this person had come back to life
and some of these people were people
that I knew later socially that he
agreed with profoundly but he would
inhabit them so effectively that you
couldn't get but get swept up in in the
enthusiasm that they had and that they
brought to their work right and of
course these folks were often in
contradiction with one another and I
thought wow that's that's the best way
to understand these authors is to kind
of live inside of them one of the things
that stands out in your answer is this
this notion of of empathy and really
understanding the person that you're
talking about teaching or or talking to
and and teaching that's an important
skill to have and and I think it would
have been great to have learned some of
the philosophy and great thinkers I
learned from a professor such as the one
you had versus the ones I had which back
in the day on acid State bullet points
just walking through their points of
view so clearly your experience was was
different than mine let me ask question
number three what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe
I'm going to say level length and levity
so when when you're communicating you
have to pick the right level meaning you
don't want to talk down to people so
part of my podcast I know it's tough for
some people but I don't want to talk
down to people but you also don't want
to talk up to people right you have to
make sure that the sophistication and
complexity of what you're saying is
within the reach of the people that
you're communicating with okay that's
number one number two length concision
is super important in a lot of contexts
but in other contexts people really want
to go deep and and figuring out the
length of someone's attention span and
calibrating what you're saying and the
level of granularity the level of detail
level of depth with their
appetite for comprehension getting that
right is is super important and then the
third thing is levity right so
you know I like humor I like using humor
there are situations where humor might
be inappropriate okay and that needs to
be serious and so you can be
too funny and I've certainly made errors
in that direction
but you can also be too serious right
and and so getting that balance of
inspiring affect and I guess you could
apply it to other emotions because
sometimes you want your the people
you're communicating to be a little bit
anxious right and so one of the reasons
why people sit in the front row is
because they want the adrenaline rush of
the professor leaning over them right
and and if you don't stimulate that by
cold calling then people don't you know
don't learn as much so so finding that
right emotional balance the
communication if there's any fear or
anxiety or levity that exceeds the
proper parameters then it'll interfere
with the with the communication
love your Three L's the notion of
finding the right level the right length
and and bringing levity in are are
definitely mantras we can all take into
account and and for many of us just
thinking about those going into a
communication event I think could really
help well Greg you did not disappoint
your podcast is called unsiloed and I
feel like our conversation was on siled
that's exactly what I was hoping for
thank you for sharing your Insight thank
you for having your podcast be part of
the GSB podcast family and it's nice to
have a fellow podcast host on on faculty
thank you thank you Matt it's great
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn
foreign